es el arrecife de coral más grande del
mundo y australia lo quiere salvar
especialmente después de que la unesco
amenazada con incluir a la gran barrera
de coral en la lista de patrimonio
mundial en peligro por su deterioro por
lo que ha anunciado un paquete de ayuda
económica vamos a comprometer esos mil
millones de dólares australianos durante
los próximos nueve años esto se suma a
los dos mil millones que ya hemos
invertido eso es cuidar del arrecife ya
sea por la ciencia ya sea por continuar
con nuestra batalla contra la estrella
de mar de corona de espinas o mejorar la
calidad de la el ecosistema natural se
ha enfrentado a tres eventos de
blanqueamiento masivo desde 2015 y de
sus trescientos cuarenta y ocho mil
kilómetros cuadrados y 411 especies
distintas de coral tan sólo el 2% de
estos animales han conseguido sortear el
blanqueamiento además la gran barrera ha
perdido el 50 por ciento de sus corales
en las últimas tres décadas un fenómeno
en el que la crisis climática tiene
mucho que ver
en la crisis climática es la mayor
amenaza para la gran barrera de coral
fue un poco chocante que este paquete no
lo menciona en absoluto entiendes
packers
los que estamos aquí en primera línea
investigando haciendo ciencia y
trabajando por la conservación de la
gran barrera de coral y de los arrecifes
de todo el mundo estamos bastante
preocupados con el gobierno de morrison
ha rehusado abordar la crisis climática
y apoya a las industrias del carbón y
del gas muy contaminantes no obstante
las encuestas muestran que más del 60
por ciento de la ciudadanía quiere
combatir este fenómeno y así poder
salvar maravillas naturales como la gran
barrera de coral